let's take another call here onward sake
Oh Galbraith coming out of California
what's up Alvarez man homework wondering
not what you think about I got fired
last week I'm a maintenance mechanic
electrician AC guy certified welder so
I'm on this boom lift
they call me down and tell me to go
working this on this toilet which I
usually don't do toilets pull the feces
master mount bro
oh yeah bruh then boo-boo cauldrons and
I used to work at a place broad that
they had you know I used to work at this
place called duck O's when I was young
and it was like a burger joint and it
was only in business for probably two
months which I didn't even know you
could be in business for two months I
mean that seemed like almost not even a
business it seemed like somebody just
having people stopped by and then
getting a little bit of their money and
that's it but so duck O's they had
burgers and cheeseburgers and they had
the famous for and that's what it was
called and it was four pieces of meat
cheese on the top cheese on the bottom
and that was the big thing I like I were
gonna put cheese on the bottom of the
burger that famous for and do people
would get sick from it I guess I don't
know if something's wrong with the meat
or something's going with the bread or
just something's wrong with [ __ ] duck
oh and the whole joint so I'm in there
Brahmas a counter boy but that's the
funny thing look when there's only two
people and employees and one of them the
boss they hire you as the counter boy
next thing you know you ain't Nair next
thing you know you in there in the
toilet with that you know that plunger
and you in there just [ __ ]
ratatouille next thing you know you're
working in that boo boo kitchen you work
in the toilets shift because they don't
have anybody else
and the owner one act like he's never
dealt with you know and like he's never
dealt with fie see and even though the
crazy thing is he's the one making the
food and selling it he's the one making
people sick and now I'm having to work
in the back streets of this
establishment in the seedy underbelly of
his own customers and dude it was the
smallest little restaurant
had three tables so people would order
from me go sit down get sick then go use
in the bathroom there was no some time
you get a bathroom there's like a little
waiting here you open the door there's
another little room and or a hallway and
then the bathrooms this [ __ ] was just
door toilet no what no and was just
gender Newton could go in there [ __ ] a
mule could go in there if it wanted to
and so you would he it was just so
bizarre but you would people would be
sick in there and it's like I'm
literally trying to take an order and
like 11 feet away from me through some
very very limited ply wall or whatever
it's called plywood very very limited
plywood you could hear somebody making
just some damn you know just that body
belt just you know making a belt out of
his bottom and just sweating and feeling
really really iottery mind you're
feeling iottery
but your booty gets Jamaican bro
sometimes you're sweating so hard not
with me
onward like like there was a time of the
door don't use it and some dude did that
I see no toilet paper all I seen was
feces oh that's a booty terrorist breath
I've been in there somebody dude I was
at an armed Falcons game one time and
they had a urinal with the bag over you
know they do that they put that plastic
bag this dude put turned his butt around
you know cut a little hole in that bag
he had a you know a sharp object or
something a little ship or a piece of
bone in his pocket he cut a little thing
in that plastic and boo-booed right into
the deal unbelievable people living out
in the world homework so I'm like I'm
not doing that you said the supervisor
goes a little fire to do we don't need
you here I do a lot for you Joe because
I also go to school night trying to get
my long-term goal here my Masters in
Social Work Oh congratulations man I
love hearing that hours I love hearing
that brother that's what you want to do
Social Work land you want to help other
people you know homeward uh try to help
gun
I'm the leather years clean
trying to go that realm you know right
now yeah so uh he helps me I want to
have to intern I'm doing some interning
at dry cleaning but I'm like I help you
- I work 16 hours it's equal I'm not
saying anything i'm just not cleaning a
toilet filled with [ __ ] i'm not doing
that he's got all manner fires me so now
I'm without a job it's been about three
four days and I started getting
depressed I start getting weird like a
man used to work but I don't know what
you think or what other guys think up
that I talked to some friends they're
like you should have just did it but I
thought that's where's the line I have a
three-year-old daughter someday I'm
gonna tell her you got to do what you
feels right self-respect is very
important but you know not having a job
is a horrible horrible feeling I got
some things lined up but I hoped here on
the podcast man I'm all about you bro
well thanks for calling me that's a
tough spot because yeah you have the
child I think you know you take a couple
of options I think you can always go
back to him if you still feel like you
know sometimes it's about being the
bigger man you know and maybe it was you
know in that day sometimes you're
feeling a certain way you could always
go back and say look I made a mistake
you know I could have done it
differently I could have said I could
have just taken the direction I just
felt like that was out of line for me
I've been there you know they had to do
it I used to wash dishes at this fancy
place called dakotas when I was growing
up in wanting some time they had a
system manager or something in there he
tried to make me eat a little bucket of
Our Lives lime slices and I don't even
not barely knew this man he was always
trying to pretend he was French and [ __ ]
but he wasn't and he was probably an
idiot or an idiot uh that's French I
don't know but anyway he tried to give
me to eat this thing of limes and said I
had to do it cuz I was an employee man
[ __ ] that bruh I ain't eating us you
know they probably had 60 lime slices in
there and I probably I was a child mal
was probably 16 I never had more than
even one lime slice and this man trying
to give me 60 lime slices and I and I
had to quit so someone's you got to
stand up for you something you got to be
a man and that's okay man there's
something going on in this world where
it's like you can't be a man these days
so you can stand up for yourself and you
can even go back
they even more man
if you want to do it or as manly you
could go back to the dude if you feel
differently in a few days and say hey I
could have handled that differently
would you consider us working again that
way is still you're meeting somebody
halfway you're not giving in you know
it's nice to be up I mean it's the you
know the most manly thing to do
sometimes is to [ __ ] get over that
little hurdle but in the moment yeah
they got you down there cleaning out
somebody else's you know dirty [ __ ]
booty aquarium come on get out of there
I'd be out I'd be out so I don't blame
you you know hold it down you know for
as long as you can and then when you
have to you know if you feel like you
know maybe take a look at some other
opportunities you said you're going back
to school so I'm sure it's probably you
know I'm sure you're in some tight
confines there with work I would if
you're okay with it I would probably
reappropriation for speck and I think
that they would respect you could say
just say cleanly like look I needed a
couple days to cool off man because the
booty work around here was a little too
hot for daddy to be down there doing you
know suddenly you out there and you to
some little booboo ratatouille and you
see no just out there working out and
some you know and somebody else's
porridge tank come on but thank you for
calling man and I love the fact that
you're moving forward do you have a plan
in your life you want to be do social
work you have a daughter you're already
thinking ahead about that you want to
tell your daughter that you stood up for
yourself that you're not afraid to be
stand up for yourself I love that I love
that man it's really really a powerful
message and I appreciate you calling in
oh you know it's crazy as my sister
can't even read but what does it have to
do with us right now hope you enjoyed
that video and you can watch another and
you can
just one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option not this
guy two options watch one this one or
this one